[MUSIC PLAYING]
IDO GREEN: Hi.
Welcome to our new
series of videos
that will bring you news
and best practices on Action
on Google.
I'm Ido Green, a developer
advocate for Action on Google.
I love to help
entrepreneurs and developers
to be more productive.
So in this video, we
are going to learn
how to build an app for Google
Assistant that use your service
logic.
Cool?
The Google Assistant gives
users their own personal Google
and help them find,
organize, and get
things done in their world.
The main way users interact
with Google Assistant
is by carrying on a
conversation with it.
You can extend the
Google Assistant
by building apps that
let users get things done
with your product and services.
Today, we are going to build
a new app for the Google
Assistant that will give us
the current bitcoin price.
Cool?
How does it work?
The users need to
invoke your app.
You say a phrase like, OK,
Google, talk to bitcoin info.
This tell Google the name
of the app to talk to.
>From this point
onwards, the user
is now talking to your app.
Your app generate a
dialog output, which
is then spoken to the user.
The user then make
request, your app
process it, and
replies back again.
The user has two-way dialogue
until the conversation
is finished.
Let's go to the console
of API.AI and log in.
Once you click
the Google button,
you will get an option to
create your first app, or agent,
in the API.AI terminology.
API.AI agent will enable our
app to phrase the user request
and trigger the
fulfillment for our app.
We'll be able to return
with the right answer.
After the login, you could
create the first API.AI agent.
What are entities?
Entities are the value type.
They help us group
items by their type.
We are trying to capture
from the user phrases,
kind of like filling out
the form requesting details
from the user.
API.AI look to
extract those out.
And we will do the follow-up
prompts until done.
This is our entity's
look in API.AI.
Let's build the WebHook.
We've got for you two options
here, either build it yourself
or, if you don't have a
service running right now,
you could use our WebHook
by just plugging it
into your fulfillment.
If you wish to test the
WebHook from your own servers,
you could take the code below
and use your own servers
with node.js.
This is the index.js that
contain all the logic
for our WebHook.
Let's create our intents.
What is an intent?
An intent is triggered by a
series of user says phrases.
This could be
something like, please
tell me what is the bitcoin
value in US dollars,
or what is the
blockchain size today.
In most cases, you need
to specify 10, 12 phrases
to train API.AI's machine
learning algorithms.
Then, even if the user doesn't
say exactly the words you type
here, API can still
understand them.
You should create
separate intents
for different types of action.
Don't try to combine
them all together.
In our examples, we'll
create only two intents--
price intent-- this intent
will handle the main action,
fetching the bitcoin price--
and a quit intent.
This intent will handle
the part where the user
wishes to exit the app.
Build the price intent.
After we have our own
new currency entity,
if you notice the at before
the word, it's not a mistake.
This is the way
that we will refer
to our new entity from now on.
Think of it as a new
special sign to show us
that we are referring to
our new entity, and not
just another bitcoin.
It's time to create the intent
that will fetch us the bitcoin
information.
First click on the
Create Intent button.
Second, start typing
a few sentences
that you will want to use to
get information on bitcoin.
For example, please tell
me what is the value
of bitcoin today in US dollars.
Type a few sentences
so API.AI can
start training its algorithms.
You could see that,
while you type,
API.AI automatically
recognize the phrases includes
one of the entities.
So it's highlighted.
Next, we are skipping
the events part.
And in the API.AI
Action section,
we need, one, to type price
as the action name that we
will pass to our WebHook.
You could think of it as
our key for this intent
when invoking the WebHook.
This information will let us
run the right functionality
in the WebHook.
Make sure that our
current entity is not
required, as in this
video, we are not
going to use it due to
the time limitation.
However, if you wish
to extend it later,
you could require it
and have several options
to get the value of the bitcoin
in different currencies.
Finally, in the
Fulfillment section,
you need to check
the WebHook checkbox.
But before we could
do that, you need
to click on the Fulfillment
menu item and enable WebHook.
After you enable it,
you will get the option
to enter your
WebHook parameters.
In this phase, you
could just fill the URL
that we gave you in the demo.
Now click Save, and
return to the intent,
and click on Price Intent.
Scroll all the way
down, and you'll
see the new option, Fulfillment.
Please make sure to
check the two checkboxes
so API.AI will know to send
this information to our WebHook.
Let's build our Quit intent.
A good design principle
is to allow our users
to end the conversation.
You should click again
on Create Intent button,
then start typing
a few sentences
that you will want to see when
you're ending the conversation.
For example, bye-bye,
or quit bitcoin info.
Below is how this
content will look like.
You need to check the
End Conversation checkbox
so that it will
know to really end
the conversation at this point.
Let's test the price intent.
It's very important
to check your work
while you are developing it.
Luckily for us, it's very
easy to do with API.AI.
All you need to do is, after
that you create the intents,
is to look at the right
side of the screen.
Type what you wish to test,
and you will get the response.
In the example below,
we type, please
tell me what is the price
of bitcoin in US dollars.
And as you can see here,
it's working nicely,
since we got the
price in the response.
A quick way to test
how our new app works
on Google Home and
other devices will
be to use our web simulator.
We need to click on Integrations
in the left side menu,
and then click on Publish
checkbox in the top right side.
On Actions on Google, as
it will be our integration.
Click on the Test button.
If this is the first time you
are enabling the integration,
you will need to click on the
switch at the top right corner
to enable this integration.
The next step is to
click on View in order
to open the Actions
on Google simulator.
You can see it in the image.
You'll get a screen that lets
you talk with the simulator.
On the left side, you can
type or talk your commands,
and on the right
side, you can see
the response in a JSON format.
Here, we get the
full conversation
that tests our two intents.
If the web simulators
give you an error,
then you need to click on
this link and activate it.
We could also test our action
with the automatic page
that API.AI created
for our new app.
First you need to click on
Deploy so the new app will
be available to the world.
Then, you need to customize
the URL so it will be easier
to remember it.
In our case, we
type bitcoin info.
Now you could try it.
It's very powerful,
as you could now
share your creation
with the world,
and it will work
on any device that
is connected to the
internet and got a browser.
That's it for today.
Good job.
Thank you for watching.
We'd love your feedback, so
please don't be a stranger,
and leave us comments below.
Until next time, be strong,
and create an amazing Assistant
apps.
Bye-bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]